est-ce que vous avez aimé tamara tamara
un oui oui alors vous allez adorer
tamara mieux bah oui parce qu'en fait
les deux ils ont grandi parmi eux en
fait il était en fait vous étiez
ensemble puis séparés de diego il
fallait oublier le beau gosse navy à huy
alors donc qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle
part à faire ses études à paris a loué
un appartement colloque et qu'elle
retrouve soir voilà voilà
le bordel à la whey la bande annonce sur
le parc juste après quand je mets jouer
suis moi ton avis pourquoi génial
pour cent du jeu d'aventuré vous du rêve
la chambre bureau la salle de bain avec
la baignoire sabot comme à l'époque mais
du coup on mange dans la baignoire
ça se fait plus en plus on peut habiter
avec wagner juge alors tu l'aimés 150
mètres carrés on trouvera jamais lieu
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui fait la jeune rencontrer
mes nouveaux collègues et sa part de
recraqué c'est sa maman
moi je m'en fous de julien celle est un
exemple j'ai réfléchi ça va c'est pas
quantifié j'avais mal en fait et le dis
qu'il faut sa meuf
je crois que c'est à chaque fois que
j'investis et s'est un peu perdu excuse
moi tu vois moi je t'aime et je
t'aimerai toujours je suis là depuis le
début
c'est très gênant ce qui va se passer la
barre à deux ça soit le 4 juillet et à
mon avis ça va marcher parce que c'est
très bon enfant c'est sympa sa seconde
nuit adoré adoré c'est votre
combientième rôle au cinéma
mon deuxième après tamara comment il est
le petit ryan
comment il allait manger tous les ados
ravages lada c'est un super bon ami à
moi à vous êtes vous êtes amis dans les
rangs des très bas on est très amis avec
tamara depuis le matériel et les
premiers real m'appelle tamarins parce
que j'ai pas comme ils s'appellent en
vrai mais à 90 yeux on est on est très
proches depuis le depuis le premier donc
le deuxième c'était même pas une des
retrouvailles c'était vraiment c'était
une effusion de bonheur exactement
alors regardez un extrait où justement
vos deux personnages se retrouvent pour
l'avoir fois après quelques années de
séparation le choc
bah
qu'est ce que tu fais
je n'ai pas traité sur paris bah non
match n'a pas donné de nouvelles depuis
au moins non mon général vers celle qui
rappelle forcément je me suis consacré à
la natation
et ça marche oui j'étais prévention club
de paris à quoi c'est bien je suis
contente pour toi moi si c'est justifié
la du coup je suis venu rencontrer mes
nouveaux collègues
houcine camara nous qui sortons le 4
juillet le 4 le 4 juillet le 4 juillet
sort ça m'allume 2
c'est deux fois plus drôle deux fois
mieux fait deux fois mieux jouer ouais
deux fois mieux et même j'aurais pas vu
numéro un on arrive à suivre
c'est frais c'est drôle à ses
adversaires ici on a vu le numéro un on
adore le numéro 2 forcément forcément et
sa version culinaire l appellerons
tarama franchement non report vous avez
été un bon début mais là non me poser
une petite question à eloïse à ce matin
dans le parisien apparemment vous êtes
pressenti pour faire danse avec les
stars est ce que pouvait confirmer
l'information
on dit tout désolé c'est mais non
confirmée ou non
approchez-vous et j'ai passé le casting
encore de réponse donc si la réponse
c'est votre avis répond 2e ou c'est le
cas pour votre réponse
non c'est moi qui attend la réponse à ta
vraiment ça vous quelque chose qui vous
reviennent en ayant parlé mais pas dans
toute histoire tamara même année ce que
tu viens et ouais bah j'adorais mon avis
c'est fait ça semble m moi je vous
prendrai à mon avis je suis la preuve je
te prends tout à ouest france
oui et non c'est le dense dans tamara
deux ont fini en fait
qui a été fait en plus par des knicks
économisera qui dansent à ogeu l'adorent
elle a donc s'est offert un petit point
sur le cas c'est le savez c'est quoi
alors on là bas noirs anwar loïse
héloïse actuellement rio dans ces
mondiaux sur piste sera ni de koh lanta
ouais basile boli qu'a été annoncée la
partie anna mais c'est génial basile
boli
les jeunes vont dans tous les sens tard
on aime on n'aime pas c'est une star
basile boli senden métrage ya pas que
des stars tu n'es toujours on savait
qu'il est sur l'enseigné grand fait
d'armes
comment son grand fait d'armes si les
marques et surtout un but en finale de
la coupe d'europe c'est la seule fois où
française aura sapin matheuse pour
[ __ ] je sais que c'est un des mecs et
plus respectée dans le milieu et en les
brûlant brass band 3